[Music]
we will be going over one of my games
actually it's a very interesting game is
played against Grand Master Yoda showman
in 2010 I'm playing with the white
pieces this game so FK d 4 D 5 c4 e6 go
Knight c3 and now he played c6 do you
know why he decided to play this setup
with the e6 move first see because looks
like he could have also just played d4
d5 right c4 e6 c6 and Knight c3 and then
a 6 but if he plays this way what
additional lines I can play against this
setup
that I cannot play against if he plays
with for example in this position this
move like I cannot really take on d5
here because then he just takes back no
no no no in this position for example I
cannot take C takes d5 but let's say if
you play c6 I have the option of playing
C takes d5 the exchange violation of the
Slav it's not like it's something that
you know like really needs to worry
about but if the player has black
doesn't really play these positions you
know he might feel a little bit
uncomfortable going into the Slav
exchange if he doesn't nodal all the
lines up-to-date so that's why you D
plays this way with ecigs
in order to avoid the exchange Slav
lines so we know each other very well so
we even play the match
so we've played lots of games against
each other so we know our the opening so
I played c6 but against this setup now
of course I can just play III in this
position which will be the you know
normal III Knight f3 but in this game I
decided to play the sharp E for this
move leads into to a pawn sacrifice but
I had some preparation and in fact it
was funny we actually prepared together
some of these lines so he knew it very
well also you know I was coaching the
team in 2010 at all in p8 and I was not
playing so he actually won a game with
black against a strong clash but I
decided to give it a try I don't
normally play this move before so this
was I think the first time that I
decided to play so I play E for now line
goes D takes e4 Knight xe4 and Bishop
before check and here basically white
needs to play Bishop d2 which is the
main line but also Knight c3 move is
played a couple of times I've seen maybe
a lot of times actually played but the
game I can remember and in fact
Grandmaster Alex here molinsky he played
93 again
you're a showman so there was a game
played with that but I don't quite
believe that you can really fight for
advantage with going back with a knight
so that's why I didn't play that so my
plan was to play Bishop d2 so I went we
should be too and now if it just takes
we should be too after Queen d2 white is
slightly better I have the control of
the center little bit more development
and the problem is this Bishop on c8 so
Bishop d2 it's bad so this is the line
so he goes Queen takes d4 now is winning
the pond so equals Queen takes d4 and
now my knight is hanging so I will take
the bishop bishop takes before and now
he plays his Queen takes e4 check so
this is a very sharp line and there are
many games played in this opening so now
black is up upon but his dark squares
are a little bit weak and white has the
pair of the bishops so it's this
position that depends on a player some
players really like to play these
positions and some players really don't
like so it depends how much you really
analyze this position so but it's very
sharp so all three results possible here
so they've been some games for black one
in 20 moves 25 months and white won many
games so I decided to go now Bishop e2
okay my idea to go Bishop e2 and he
played Knight a six and here White has
couple of options you can play Bishop d6
one of the main moves Bishop a5 is the
move that I played there is also this
Bishop f8 move here actually because
it's it's a phantom who you cannot take
because Queen d8 may but I don't think
it really does much here because looks
like we know five and so Queen e5 just
protects this so but my idea was that
said okay if you replace this line I
will play Bishop here
so I play Bishop a5 well I'm just
starting mate Queen takes the eight mate
and here he played f6 and a lot of move
here is b6 that he can also try in this
position so when I was preparing I
wasn't so sure which line he is going to
play is gonna play f6 there b6 or f6 but
I remember that f6 in you know my
analysis was like you know maybe this is
a little bit you know dubious because
you know it's weakening the position so
he played f6 now I just play Knight f3
my idea is just simply to develop and
cancel and then after f6 there will be
some weaknesses I was hoping that I will
have some compensation and since I have
also the bishop so I thought okay I can
do something so you played b6 and now I
want you to think about it because here
you're gonna see lots of in-between
moves and these are the moves that you
know sometimes we don't look for we're
thinking of opponent makes a move
attacking our piece and we think
immediately or we have to move it but
not always you have to think like that
sometimes you have to look for in
between moves like in this position I
didn't move my Bishop can you find the
move that I played here
so what I want to do is I want to try to
create some more weaknesses as you can
see he has pushed some of his pants if I
can you know force him at least to play
g6 again this will be weakening
additionally the position so what can
you do here
well your Bishop is hanging so you have
to make a move that is attacking
something instead of just moving which
piece you think you can attack here
Quinn right so can we find a good move
to attack his Queen here absolutely we
can I do t2 and now attack his queen
he cannot take the pawn why why can't he
take the pawn on g2 well not this one on
g2 if he goes quintet g2 is losing
bishop after each attack the Queen and
then check here pick up the rock so he
cannot take on g2 we know that now so he
cannot play that so he needs to move the
Queen again and as you can see now he's
moving his queen a lot so more he moves
his Queen it's better for me that means
he's not developing his pieces but again
this is a very concrete position now he
goes Queen a for now see I'm still not
moving my bishop here because now I have
an opportunity to create some more
weaknesses what can you do to create
some more weaknesses now blacks position
here bishop check absolutely now he
played g6 blocking it and now suddenly I
have my both bishops is suggesting on
the side of the board and they're both
hanging
but now which move I can play now to
attack something well
Bishop f3 yes now I go back push wave 3
see I could have gone Bishop f3 first
but it's it's better for me to induce
this g6 because it's gonna be weakening
so I go Bishop f3 now I want to take on
c6 check and then pick up the rock see
I'm not too worried about my bishop yet
here I mean all this was my preparation
during the game it's not like I played
also but you know it's it's very
interesting ideas to do you weaken the
position and then you come back you
attack on c6 so he has to now something
after Bishop f3 and he played night he
played Knight 7 he protected it so at
this point I will bring my Bishop back
CH much better for me with the bishop on
c3 the pawn is on g6 then on g7 on g7 it
would have been protected but on g6 now
I have some more pressure so he needs to
protect this so Bishop c3 castle castle
so now in this position he decided to
bring his Queen back because Queen is
vulnerable again I can play g3 so he
decided to bring it back and now I want
you to spend some time here maybe two
three minutes and I would like you to
think about this position and evaluate
it okay so let's say who you think is
better here black is up upon but it's
got this funny pounds here a little bit
and develop and so what's the evaluation
of this position what do you think here
is that white is better black is better
or equal what do you think here and what
would be the best continuation also for
white we need to evaluate the position
and also find a best follow-up
that that's the move I played yes and
what would be the evaluation of this
position who is better here white black
and why white is better
haha two bishops bad a little bit weak
what else AHA what else we can mention
about Knights on the edge mm-hmm a lot
of pawn moves has been played a lot of
Queen moves has been played right and
who has the leading development
white right so if you come if you add
all these factors it's very it's pretty
clear now in this position that you want
to play us white because you have two
bishops leading development his pawn
structure is kind of weak and weak
squares weak pawns and night is on the
side so black needs lot of moves here to
coordinate his position here even though
he's got extra pawn but you know he can
only convert the extra pawn in the
endgame right now he has a lots of
fighting problems here and the movies of
course 94 activating the knight
centralizing it and also immediately
attacking one of six and now he needs to
find the only move which is e5 of course
to block the bishop and now it looks
like okay what's next now what can I do
because if I play slowly then he will
develop his pieces and he will
coordinate and he will be fine but now
you need to make him another move and
create a threat can you find this move
here every move I make I try to create
some threats
so which move would be the best
excellent excellent
see I simply develop another piece here
now the threat is let's just see if
let's say he moves the bishop here
losing already because of 90 xf6
Tec again you see why forced into 3 g6
because I wanted him not to you know
have this pawn weak so takes we should
be 5 takes attacking the rook and the
quaint so so now winning the rook and
it's losing down so so when I played
this move rook e1 I'm creating a threat
of Knight f6 and the good thing is I'm
also developing a piece since I'm
creating a thread that means he cannot
just normally develop his pieces because
he needs to worry about my threat and
now he found I think it's one of the
only moves he has here actually because
I'm not sure if he can do anything else
here so he played Queen d7 but again
moving the Queen so let's count how many
times the Queen moved 1 2 3 4 5 lots of
Queen moves I mean this is the kind of
the opening is like that you move a lot
but still 5 moves with the Queen lots of
pawn moves and some development so it
looks at least risky this position go
back
ok now Queen d7 now the question for you
do I want to go to endgame here yeah
okay okay think about it do you want to
go to endgame here when you're down upon
no right and a position like this you
want to make sure you keep the Queen's
on the fortress because you can try to
attack now again you make a move and
create a threat so remember you have to
always make some moves and create
threats
I'm actually very logical moves the next
few moves it's creepy tree you could but
you know I'm more wanna be closer to the
suicide center enough to go to the
queenside yes Knight f6 here but now
it's not so clear because you can just
take because he already moved his queen
so I won't be able to take with 10:45 so
what else I don't want to exchange the
Queen's okay you don't Quincy - is that
the best quad for the Queen here don't
want to go away you're going away you
know I want to be closer here Queen to
it oh because you have to make a move
and create a threat but you have to see
the thread so you know which move to
make here who can tell me what is the
thread after Queenie - what am I trying
to do here excellent I'm threatening to
take on f6 he takes back with this and
after Queen e5 game is over because he
cannot protect the f6 and you cannot
defend the diagonal okay remember this
is diagonal yeah battery we have and now
if the rook moves we have a checkmate
from g7 and h8 so it's losing so again
developing and creating threats so now
he needs to again spend some time to
defend against that threat so now he
plays Queen e2 26 defending the threat
only move and now what will be the most
logical move in this position
what do you think here and you still
want to continue absolutely a rook to d1
and again creating a threat and what is
the threat do you see the threat
absolutely Luke comes to d6 it will be
over because I take on f6 and break
through I have excellent development and
basically buck is barely hanging on here
but it's not so easy here because now he
found again good move Knight f5 and it's
controlling the d6 square if you didn't
have this no after Luke the six I think
it's probably losing now now we reach
this position where okay I developed all
my pieces they're very nice they're
centralized but I'm still down the pond
and I can't really do anything right now
so when you look at this position now
you think of can you gain some more
space and possibly create some threats
in this position
however we will focus on this diagonal
but we also have another bishop on this
diagonal and this is very important here
what can you do to create some more
space
push pants which buns be for very good
we go before now gaining more space and
now with some potential threats will be
five okay and now in this position he
played after I play before he played 97
the night is on the side of the board
not doing anything so he's trying it's a
logical move to bring into the game and
after he played 97 I spent some time
here calculating what I can try to do
and came up with this very interesting
sacrifice that will allow me to win lot
of pawns and the most important thing I
will open up the position and when you
have two bishops you always want to open
the position okay so aha very good very
good you sacrifice the night it's not
like I'm winning but I position is gonna
be open and he doesn't have good
development so how do we do that yeah
how do we do that here
of course you know if he goes 98 he may
consolidate the position what can you do
here excellent excellent job 9 takes f6
sacrifice now because while he's not
developed if I'm gonna do something like
this this is the right time because he
doesn't have development if he has more
development it would be more difficult 9
takes f6 he went Queen takes f6 now we
go we don't want to exchange Queens
right bishop takes e5 now attacking the
knight and the Queen
so he goes Queen to f7 ok so he goes
Queen to a7 and now let's take the pawn
on c6 - now let's look at this position
I'm down a piece but I have 2 pounds
very strong bishops his King is exposed
and now I'm also attacking the rook this
is more than enough compensation for the
piece ok but still it's not like I'm
waiting here bishop c6 he goes rook b8
what to do now because I need to find
the right plan here again
take out the night quintics
he moves away yeah
so in a position by this now you have to
look at the position see which pieces
the way I found the next move I just
looked at the position and say hmm I
know I have a good position but how can
I improve one of my pieces and if you
look at the position here which piece
you think I'm trying to improve here
very good Queen right because bishops
are excellent the rooks are perfect so
this is the piece that is kind of
unclear what is she doing here where do
you want to put this Queen so you have
some more threats what do you think well
don't worry about c4 pound because it's
something he needs to protect his knight
he doesn't have time to take that pawn
no worries about the c4 pawn right now
you could put on b2 I was thinking I
actually spent some time here because I
had some ideas maybe you couldn't pull
the bishop back here and go Queen B to
some battery but it wasn't so clear so I
don't want to put it on b2 because then
this would be kind of not the most
effective battery not because I wanted
to have other way around so I can go
Queen eh-eh this way I don't know if I
can do much g4 in a positions like this
you want to be very careful when you
play g4 because you have to control you
have the control almost the whole board
but it when you play g4 then it was
night h4 he's gonna start threatening
some threats so he will have some
threats Queen g4 yeah well
Oh Queen G food no Queen g4 better
better something better you have no
because g4 was actually an idea that I
was considering in some positions
well I actually I actually thought about
that before move definitely I considered
before but it's it's not so clear
because yeah it's see the thing is when
you playing a game
afterwards when you analyze of course
computer will show you something where
but during the game
g4 it's not this position earlier okay
but g4 it's it's cool I also analyze
that later but it's such a move that you
know bit risky I kind of like this
position you know it's it's I feel like
I'm more control here no no we need to
improve the Queen yes Queen to e4 well
you need to kind of keep your eye on
this f2 pawn because no no I played
Queen d2
if you look at this position can you
find a good move for black I mean try to
find a move for black that it's not
losing something that's the problem for
black-ish he just doesn't have a good
move Bishop d7 loses to Bishop d7 this
is very important sequence actually
because I go Bishop d7 and he cannot
protect this knight on c7 and now I'm
actually threatening to take the knight
and even if you take back with the rook
I hope we should be six winning the
Queen so that's the problem here it's
just basically it's a strange position
but you know he's got a extra piece
buddy so it's almost insuk's along here
he has no good move here so after Queen
d2 he found I think that I think he
found the only move again was I really
can't see a move here for him that is
not making his position worse now Bishop
to e6 losses I take the knight and then
I take the bishop which Knight well you
lose your rock he's like he's it's kind
of pinned you know everywhere so he
played the only move Knight g7 okay now
he's putting some pressure at least he's
trying to do something now at this point
I want a winning exchange because I
already have two pounds if I win the
exchange I will be I will be ahead here
so how can I win the exchange here I
might be able to just continue playing
positionally just for compensation but I
felt like you know if I can win the
exchange you know and I have two pounds
I also will have the material advantage
so how can I win the exchange here
how can you win this rock
Bishop to d5 excellent now threatening
to win the Queen he doesn't have
anything better but to take okay because
let's say he plays Bishop e6 I go Bishop
takes e7 attacking the rook so if he
takes on d5 I can take on b8 he loses if
he takes with the Queen I simply take
only six Czech Knight captures rook
captures and white will have two extra
pounds and a winning position so he
cannot do that
so he took Knight takes d5 and now we go
Bishop takes b8 and now still I actually
still have the initiative here because
now his Knight is still hanging and his
darks words are very weak
okay now I have the ham up exchange and
have two pumps so I have a rook five
pounds and two pounds I have seven he
has two pieces so yes he's you know
technically is down upon but also his
position is very difficult now so it was
Knight f6 now I bring my bishop into the
game Bishop d6 attacking the rook so he
goes rook b8 and now he's pinning me so
I need to move my Queen to a good square
so I'm no longer pinned and also have
some pressure on the dark squares which
Square will be the best here for white
you could wait for but then you have to
worry about this Knight jumping and
attacking you you want to put the Queen
somewhere that these nights are not
annoying you with the tax all the time
well again equals 95 and he's attacking
absolutely Queen C three very good
square putting pressure on the diagonal
and in some point I'm also planning to
push the C pawn push because I can
create the past month so that's what I
want to do so he went Knight f5
activating his knight attacking the
bishop I simply go now Bishop to e5
offering the exchange of the rooks
exchange of the rooks will be useful for
me because then he will have background
problems also on top of you know the
weak diagonals so that's why he when I
played Bishop e5 he didn't want to
exchange so he played Knight d7 but now
he's spinning himself so he's spinning
himself and now strong move you need to
find for white to keep the initiative
going c5 excellent very good c5 right
this is the right time to push the spawn
because now I'm trading to play c6 okay
he takes I take again I'm threatening to
play c6
so he goes hook f8 and now what do you
do now
Bishop you could do that but he's gonna
take and then f2 is hanging okay so you
want to do something better here
something better
absolutely if you have a passed pawn you
continue pushing it more you push
stronger it's gonna get remember that's
the rule when you have a passed pawn
when nothing in front of it can sponsor
you push and it's gonna get stronger
right so I push he takes only five I
take with the Queen because I want to
have a centralized Queen okay now my
queen is in the center is centralized
guarding many squares and my rooks are
on the open file and I want to just
continue pushing this pawn and then I
have the rook d8 idea as well so now my
opponent took this pawn and he took the
pawn trying to activate now what do you
do
push pawn absolutely you don't stop you
continue pushing it and now he plays
Knight g7 try to defend but also
creating a threat of on f2c he wants to
take now on f2 now what can you do here
can you push it back now so we have to
defend against his threat yeah but it's
important you keep the temples keep the
temples now can you defend and attack
something excellent rookie - very good
now attack the Queen okay now he goes
Queen e6 he's offering the exchange of
the Queens and he is hoping that he can
neutralize this pawn but it's not gonna
be easy so what do I do now how now
white is already winning how
when you have a pawn like this what's
the logical thing to do push the rock
right you push the rock there because
you want him to take right so you can
take and Queen that's what you do now
now I play rock d8 so he takes I take
and it's possible that my opponent was
counting on this move because it's not
so clear because if I take he takes
maybe he can walk and win the pawn but
this move is very important after this
move it's going to be clear that white
will be winning in couple of more moves
very nice move this one you need to find
Bishop takes
see now he is already threatening to
take you he takes you you take he takes
it so that's what he's trying to do so
you need to protect that yeah what can
you do
well if I take the bishop he takes then
I win the night but then he takes my
pawn and then it will probably a big
draw I have to make a loft and it's
gonna be a draw yes
rook takes the knight the problem is he
just takes with a bishop and we can't
even if you move this bishop we can't
still Quinn because he can take back
with the same piece so so imagine this
when you exchange these rocks where do
you want this look to be same file right
so what can - there you go the rook to
d5 now let's see now what's gonna happen
so it looks like few things you can try
to do he can take the pawn on c7 but now
if it takes on d8 you can just take back
with a pawn and you have your rook
already protecting it so you cannot do
that so here after I played rook II d5
he played Bishop b7 we'll look at that
move but now if it takes Knight takes c7
what do you do we capture the rook
capture the room and now absolutely you
can go rook up take the bishop you can
also go rook c5 and you also winning you
know actually it looks e5 looks like I'd
be a little bit more precise but both
moves are winning so he can actually win
my pawn but at the end he's gonna lose a
piece and then he will be clearly down
exchange which is losing so at this
point when I played 96 yeah this was the
basically the the final final move that
I really needed to find after this it's
already technically technically winning
so rook c5 he plays we should be 7
now what do you do
take the rook correct King takes check
again see like we always put our rooks
on the 8th but thanks to this pawn he
can never take it ok so that's why
always remember that when you have a
passed pawn you push as much as you can
so now check and he pay King is 7 and
now Queen right
we queen and yeah so now if it takes I
simply take and I'm also winning the a
pawn here okay because if you place a 5
I get behind it and if he goes here
what's the most precise move to win the
pawn on a 6 huh see because if you just
go behind it he goes 97 it's still
winning but huh c6 that's c6 yeah yeah
first you attack because he can't go 97
c5 you control that so he's gonna push
and when he pushes you get behind it and
you win the pawn okay so he played he
actually see he when I quit he didn't
take and just just couple of more moves
was played he took on d8 here he took on
d8 and I played Queen c7 check there are
some positions where you can have a
fortress but not this one because I also
have many pawns so let's say if I didn't
have my pawns there are some positions
that you know black can't set up a
fortress but not when I have my pawns
here so he goes King h7 then I simply
yeah I guess he just played a couple of
more moves and g5
gee check King d7 Quint xg5 and 96 was
played Queen III attacking the pawn pay
six and after age 40 yeah this last five
moves are doesn't matter just just this
I just start pushing the edge pawn he
resigned here because not much you can
do so again lots of lots of ideas you
know in the opening that you see in this
sharp gambit where he sacrifice upon so
but you play you continue playing
logically after you created the
weaknesses you continue developing your
pieces okay the opening of this game
again it's a marshall gambit okay he
tried to play the same e slough and i
responded with a gambit and remember
gambit is when you sacrifice something
in opening usually upon it's called the
gambit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]